Good morning,
think back to the pain of having your homeland taken away.We will not
give up.Through the sea, the sky, and the earth, we will
take back the earth that was taken away by the Machine Life Corps.
[Music] From the Dai
System What do we understand?
So, do you think you can win? My
name is Pascal, and I am the leader of this village.The
people you believe in will fight with the belief that they will overcome it someday.It looks like we will take
away the sins we caused.The success of this operation.  Please
do your best to end this conflict right here and now.Operations have begun.If you say you can do it, you
can do
it.Glory to humanity.That's the
play.Sushi.